he's british wonderful young man i
didn't want to like him
yeah but i he's he's a good kid
malia obama's boyfriend is barack obama
approved
during a recent appearance on the bill
simmons podcast the former president
opened up about family life
during the pandemic with wife michelle
and daughters
sasha and malia like i think a lot of
families
we went through that first month where
we were playing games every night and
doing a little arts and crafts projects
and then slowly you know they started
getting a little bored with us
maybe teaching uh malia and sasha
and malia's boyfriend who was with us
for a while spades
and then having some spades games um
that's contentious yeah you know and
teaching them how to
properly trash talk and slap the cards
down
yep 22 year old malia's boyfriend
quarantined with the family at the start
of the pandemic
but who is he well malia has been linked
to rory farkasen
a 22 year old fellow harvard student
since 2017.
i'm more stunned that malia's boyfriend
was quarantined with you this is the
biggest revelation of the podcast he's
he's he's uh he's british wonderful
young man
um uh and he was sort of stuck
because there was a whole visa thing and
he had a job set up
uh and so uh so we took him in
and i didn't want to like him yeah
but i he's he's a good kid young men
eat it's weird to to watch them
consume food and uh
my grocery bill went up about 30 percent
well that's good to hear since malia is
a mini barack
and he recently revealed on jimmy kimmel
live that 19 year old sasha is a mini
michelle
i'm afraid of michelle and sasha having
seen that you know basically has the
same look
and the same attitude uh malia is more
like me temperamentally
so uh and we call ourselves the long
faces
uh because her face is more shaped like
mine and it's
the round faces are michelle and sasha
and and the round faces are a fiercer
tribe
you know we're like we're like the
vegetarians the you know
the the gatherers and they're the
hunters we we we
try to you know keep the peace with them
i'm i'm generally the brunt of jokes at
your house
obama has been opening up about family
life while on tour promoting his new
memoir a promised land
i'm curious about the title i think a
lot of people
feel that we are farther from a promised
land
well i i titled it the promised land
because even though we may not get there
in our lifetimes even if we experience
hardships and disappointments along the
way
that i at least still have faith we can
create a more perfect union not a
perfect union but a more perfect union
the book has become a best seller even
outselling the former first lady's 2018
book becoming i'm not rubbing it in
over dinner
you know i i know although in truth
michelle's attitude is uh boy you go out
and
sell some books that's fine because that
will uh
pay for some of my shoes